hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to hotel remorse the
crappiest [ __ ] I've ever seen in my
entire life
holy hell who made this mask just having
it look at me is just awful
anyway horror game I don't need to
explain anymore let's play all right
Saturday October 2nd between the times
at 2:00 and 3:00 a.m. there were several
reports made of a single gunshot heard
from a hotel the occupants of the hotel
quickly vacated the building in search
of safety except for me because
apparently I'm a really really heavy
sleeper or something oh no I'm still
typing this up I see alright [ __ ] oh
that was that gunshot that you were
talking about holy crap let me turn my
volume a little bit I wasn't ready for
that holy crap
ok all right so we're all vacating the
building now Helen is pregnant we did
not plan this but I will have to accept
it as she is the only one I love we will
get through this and we will soon be
married having the rest of our lives to
be with one another and this baby ok
this is a weird hotel I'm turning my
volume back up just because you never
know what could happen hello hello I
guess I'm the only one here and Helen's
pregnant which is good can I run I can't
run hello hi how's it going
someone behind me no no okay well this
is fun what do I do
I mean obviously I'm supposed to vacate
but there's someone who has got a gun
around here or something
why was there only one gunshot okay I'm
assuming that none of these doors are
gonna work I mean I'm willing to risk an
Easter egg being missed then seeing what
the hell's going on there it is hallway
really quiet so I'm gonna I'm gonna pop
out at me
hi how did this happen how could this
happen to me
this is not how it was meant to be we
were meant to get married and be
together forever but now she is gone why
couldn't they save her but they could
save the child she was the important
[ __ ] okay
oh here all right this is my room I
don't quite recall Oh
it's blank oh my god it's so blank
I can't believe a blank it is okay dad
open a book
oh it is what the hell I did I didn't
expect that to be a thing there seems to
be a draft in this hallway
[Applause]
Oh
Oh alrighty then
it's one of hell of a warm up for my
voice you're not the important one I'm a
mean man I have no one I'm left here
alone in this darkness its cries keep me
up at night why won't it shut up please
make it shut up just shut up
how are you I have a feeling Helens dead
I don't like this hotel I'm gonna get to
customer service I better do something
about this seems to be leaking
nightmares from finally it is silent I
thought doing this would help me but I
still cannot sleep what have I done my
mind is lost without her I need you
[Music]
don't know
no no Oh coming for me who is oh crap oh
crap which way
[Applause]
I'm dead I'm dead aren't I am i die oh
[ __ ] you ding ding ding I'm dead
no not that floor I could have gone to
any floor well it worked I can't believe
that worked with those cheesy jump
scares ah you were doing so good game I
was still good charlie behan that was
really good up until that last point I
mean you could have done better than
googling scary faces off Peter and
putting it there the rest of it was
great
oh no not poor teabag no it happened
that was really good though I enjoyed
that thoroughly I didn't enjoy it it was
a load of bull it was a load of crap it
was a big pile of poopy dung all right
let me know what you thought of this in
the comments below it wasn't that bad
it was actually pretty good up until the
cheese the ending of it so there you
have it if you want to see more scary
videos check the link in the description
or check the annotations over there if
you want players for yourself maybe this
is here and I miss down in the
description as well let me know what you
think in the comments and as always
video
[Music]